first of all so excited that you're here
so excited that you're back in the star
wars universe in such a big way
when you're on stage you're a rock star
people were freaking out screaming your
name and you know you and said it the
prequels didn't always get the best
reaction when they first came out so how
does it feel
getting that warm welcome here today
it's just been incredible you know uh
this is a real celebration of star wars
uh
you walk out and you feel you know like
you're a part of a big sports team or
you know a big rock band and uh it's a
special feeling for sure did you ever
expect especially after the prequels
wrap that you would be here in this way
no not at all no when we finished i
thought that was it uh and it's been
just such a pleasure to get to come back
and uh be a part of the star wars family
again and play this character again
it's been rather surreal i can only
imagine do you have like an emotional
experience that first time you hold the
lightsaber again or get back into
costume the whole experience has been
very very emotional uh putting the darth
vader costume back on again was
incredible you know it's such an amazing
costume
getting to you know twirl a lightsaber
again
but yeah everything about it has has
been just very special for me um you
know so many fans are excited all the
titles coming out of soca is definitely
one of them anything you can tease us
about what we can expect from you in
ahuka
i can't really say too much about that
one yet
um
but but yeah i'm looking forward to
doing more with this character but it's
safe to say that you i was just gonna
say about expanding this character that
is so amazing um anything you want to
say to the fans because i'm not gonna
lie
they scream the loudest for you out of
the entire uh you know experience
i just want to thank them you know
they mean a lot to me and
[Music]
they're the reason i'm back and we get
to do this again so
just a huge thank you i'm here for you
in the um bromance too by the way
i want you guys together all the time
all right good i like it
you